long shot here sails wide off the back wall picked
up by cousins kachuck looked to actually tip it
home but it hopped over his stick long shot here
and that active glove starts immediately and mon
tour and they survived the loss of their top
through defenseman they've got them back here
now and they have excelled rart with the centering
pass to the slot forsling shoots and scores a key
set up by rehard and a minute and two seconds
in Florida is on the board with the first of
the afternoon defensive Zone and for hey with the
pressure now blankenberg does a good job here of
taking the man but ryanh Hart wants that he knew
where barkov was he almost invites that play and
how about barov I think he's going to shoot that
puck everyone in the world does but no he slides
it over and that puts jaet Greaves in a little
bit of strain there fourth line Center he's a
right-handed shot he kills penalties he's a big
body that's really as he's grown in his career
he wasn't ready when he was here in Columbus
but now he knows what he can be and he's fit
in well Graves is going to hold here interesting
Jody thinking back to the playoffs last year in
quite a run for the Panthers who almost didn't
make it they made it as that wild card and
they were the surprise team winning the Eastern
Conference Championship and they are all effective
Puck thrown to the right wing Corner Reinhardt
tried to get a stick on it could not Danforth
centers it looking in the slot there's a shot
now good row quick feet Patrick l returning
after missing three jackets Johnny goodro down the
right wing goodro looking to pass that puck it was
slapped off his stick by linkis will dump in deep
on the right wing Rodriguez who's moved from the
first line to the third line had a whale of a
game in their previous game against Pittsburgh
his former team they did against Dallas too on
Wednesday picked up a couple goals including the
game winner get a four-point KN here's an odman
Rush Moving in fantelli centering pass knocked
out in the air very alertly There by Kent Johnson
but stolar was there to make the save good hand
eye coordination by Kent Johnson there and a nice
Fe from fantelli credit for stolar with the save
jackets Come Back Again lber able to come up with
it forsland takes the feet from hot botle across
the line moving in on that left wing as Lawrence
sharp angle shot Grieves the save can't control
the rebound sent up high here to forsley cross
ice that's eblad his shot wide cousins keep in
the zone finishes the check right across the goal
M dangerously so here's chinika two goals and
an assist first three point KN and here scores
again wow cheetah cob comes through once again
and the blue jackers have tied it up look like
a slingshot play see how see how chena's behind
him there marchenko does a great job dragging
his foot look like he might have kept it on
the line two goals the other night both coming
in the third [Applause] period and now three
goals in the last two games marchenko and good
Branson draw the assist but Florida comes right
back with a tip in front and it's two to one
under attack you can see as this battle gets
won by the by the Florida Panthers they're
in the middle of the ice but look who's all
alone down in front it's ver hay and this is a
nice play up top and look who it is Reinhardt
with the shot and it's a beautiful tip in front
that's a forward and that's one thing that's hard
to defend when you get those forwards out high
like that you know the defensive Zone coverage
gets a little bit confused and that's where ver
haag's left all alone in front what a response
from Florida [__] thrown in deep do you enjoy
those afternoon games Jody I always did I really
enjoy the afternoon game a little different
routine but you know you feel the start of
this one Jeff a lot lot of energy a lot of Buzz Y
for the head coach Pascal Vincent who you know in
practice this week they can sharpen a few things
up and get a little more footing and get healthy
rehard into the slot and Greaves shots are 93
favoring Florida who lead two to onea dumps
back in Greaves will play it himself shot from
the point there Greaves back in position able
to turn that one away away from Lindell across
cross the line hustling here is Dad for Sharp
angle shot missing the mark swept to the point
Urich again looks to the left wing here stolar
the save but a big rebound that deforth is
able to Corral now back to the point again
on to Johnny goodro traffic in front of stars in
the floorida net up high uroch unable to handle
that pass it was between his legs there good
row get some help from line line in good row
heckl with a little forearm shiver bouncing Puck
jackets get it long shot here and stolar will
hold nowl forsling shot broken stick still
left in the offensive zone forsing with a quick
attempt tough angle as
well from the drop oh Zach what a play able
to keep it in here's marchenko with a shot
in stars with his biggest save of the afternoon
face off loss but Zack rinsky stands his ground
on the line it's a big play right keep that
puck in the offensive zone and then as he sees
marchenko on that Far Side marchenko wastes
no time just a whip just keep it to just one
you can keep it to zero jaff oh incredible just
incredible if they're doing a here's kachuck with
a shot backhanded down the puck and scores
it's a power play goal with but 37 seconds
remaining and Florida lead by two yeah they're
going to keep stay on the power play here it's
a 5-minute major through this 37 seconds it's
a broken play tough for Greaves there as that
puck gets thrown out in front he look who's on
the back door right on the step I mean this is
a dangerous unit these guys are all around
it all that zone time breaks down coverage
at especially off the Stick of that guy who
talked earlier 11 goals now just automatic
that's just a regular season forgetting just how
effective he was in that Tampa playoff series and
here the jacket are back to within one as
they sweep it home in the blue paint it's
32 and there's still 349 left it's an
opportunistic play just want to get PU the blue
paint and as they get set up the big man baronov
it's his office it's where he's most comfortable
and as he gets his Puck off of a play of the wall
he's going to be there to put it in the open net
and stolar gets locked up on the post and the Blue
Jackets back within one here wow stoar trying to
see the puck I'll tell you GES out again extra
attacker out and here the puck cleared running
towards the net and in that was kachu fifth of the
year and it's deep from the hash marks in his own
end I thought that for hey moment would have been
a key one as they mount their comeback but kachuck
just gets it and flips it out and Patrick l cannot
get to it right in the middle of the net 107 left
jackets with six skaters on here from the drop
Florida with it they'll send it right back into
the [Applause] net so the Blue Jackets here yeah
it's just empty net time and that's his garbage
time clock winding down final seconds
of this [Applause] one and that's it